when Ernest Cline's novel ready player
one came out in 2011 it was quickly
dubbed the holy grail of pop culture
thanks to the truckloads of pop-culture
references and easter eggs stuffed
inside its pages the entire story is one
big search for a literal egg so that
should tell you something true to its
roots Steven Spielberg's film is also a
basketful ready player one is so full of
pop-culture references that you'd be
hard-pressed to spot them all with ten
viewings let alone just one here are all
their easter eggs we found and ready
player one spoilers ahead even if you've
read the book tomb of horrors the ready
player one book made a big deal out of
Dungeons & Dragons imagery when Holliday
tells the world about his Easter egg
challenge he does so by mimicking the
cover up an old advanced D&D Dungeon
Master's guide other references come
into play here and there in the book
storyline but the movie decided to
jettison most of them that said there is
still one very visual Dungeons & Dragons
reference in the movie in the later
stages of the film Wade meets up with
his oasis buds in real life and spends
the rest of the time in H's converted
male van on the back of the van as an
image of a demon figure with two horns
the indie fans may have recognized
there's a devil's head seen in a module
called tomb of Horus femme fatales
calling out every single character cameo
and ready player one is an almost
impossible task but we do have to give a
shout-out to the ladies on the screen in
the moments leading up to the massive
battle outside castle anorak you can see
several leading ladies charging into the
fray chun-li from Street Fighter can be
seen running right beside tracer from
overwatch and behind them you can just
make our Lara Croft from Tomb Raider
other heroine appearances include Adam
Ripley from aliens as well as Sommers
from the Metroid series who shows up as
one of the dancers in the destructed
globe even Zelda shows up during the
final battle fighting right alongside
linking Ganondorf serenity the cult
series Firefly enjoyed a second life
through the movie serenity and now ready
player one marks the second film
appearance of the series iconic ship
serenity or at least some kind of fire
fight class spaceship it first appears
outside the destructed globe the dance
club planet where Wade and Artemis meet
up the second appearance of serenity
comes closer to the end of the film when
it soars out over the battle and then
Taito leaps from his loading bay to join
the war on planet doom we still would
have liked to see Captain Mal
but we'll take what we can get Star
Tribune Spielberg apparently spent years
getting the rights to use Star Wars
characters and ready player one and
after all that work references to the
sci-fi juggernaut are still incredibly
hard to spot so if you look very
carefully you'll see a couple of you'll
see an r2d2 somewhere you'll see an
x-wing somewhere the wall Star Wars got
a few cartoon odds Star Trek got an
entire scene recreation well more or
less the scene in question appears when
holidays death is first announced and he
releases his Easter Egg video to the
world at the very beginning of that
video he's seen lying in a coffin
reminiscent of Sparks coffin in Star
Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan
the Starfleet insignia is even visible
as a flower wreath to draw in the scene
sneaking it past Spielberg despite all
the references to Spielberg's films in
the book the director was keen to leave
those out of the ready player one movie
because he didn't want the whole thing
to become too self referential aside
from some Back to the Future gags and
the t-rex there are no spielberg
sanctioned spielberg easter eggs in the
movie but that didn't stop the
production team they just had to get
even more creative
for example somewhere in with all those
characters in the final oasis battle
supposedly there's one little gremlin
fighting in the mix no III didn't even
notice a gremlin show a couple of times
that I had been working on the effect
shots and I remember after about four
times seeing the same shot I said who
snuck a gremlin in this Zemeckis cube
Spielberg may have clamped down on
references to many of his films but back
to the future sure got a lot of love and
ready player one that the Lorien that
way drives in the Oasis is a most
obvious example and there was this line
I'll wave to you from the finish line
McFly but there were several more
obscure Easter eggs from the franchise
hidden throughout the film inside h's
Oasis workshop eagle-eyed viewers can
spot a hoverboard from Back to the
Future 2 but the best one has got to go
to the Zemeckis cube the magical
artifact Wade buys in the mall after
finding the first key the name of course
is a reference to Robert Zemeckis who
directed all three Back to the Future
films but this cease to rag went another
layer deeper when it turned out that the
Zemeckis cube had the power to turn back
time Jack Slater 3 according to a
theater marquee the cars passing the big
race scene at the beginning of the movie
Arnold Schwarzenegger was starring in a
movie called Jack Slater 3 if that name
sounds vaguely familiar there's a reason
for it in the 1993 movie Last Action
Hero Arnold Schwarzenegger stars as
Chuck Slater a character in a cheesy
action film franchise that exists only
within the movie you think you're funny
don't you
I know I am and the famous comedian and
Tiger to some title the movie playing at
the beginning of the Last Action Hero is
you guessed it Jack Slater 3 meltdown
the Iron Giant was a fantastic addition
to ready player one his appearance alone
isn't an easter egg obviously but he did
get one good Easter again after helping
the crew reach Castle anorak hni and
Jane fall down and sink into a pool of
lava but just before the metal man is
gone for good he gives them all the
thumbs-up it's a recreation of the scene
in Terminator 2 Judgment Day where
Arnie's t800 shoots John and Sarah
Connor a thumbs up as he sinks into a
vat of molten metal Mad Bulls if you
spent any amount of time alive in the
80s you probably had a mud ball if you
miss him the first time around
Mad Bulls were these rubber balls with
the monster faces that was about it so
don't worry you didn't miss out on much
during one scene artemis grabbed a
living man pool and used as a grenade
but the things were all over the rest of
the movie - there's a detailed mud ball
painted on one of the trainers and the
stacks and this behind the scenes
article from Entertainment Weekly shows
another one painted on the walls of
Artemis's rebellion headquarters weapon
cameos marbles weren't the only weird
weapons and ready player one one of the
items are Wade picks up in the Oasis
mall is the Holy Hand Grenade of Antioch
we
you may recognize from Monty Python and
the Holy Grail he later uses the Holy
Hand Grenade during the battle although
it doesn't even count to three before
throwing it there were plenty of other
weapon cameos as well for an instant you
can see a Star Trek about laughs in one
scene and in the ending battle Wade
whips out a halo rocket launcher which
he fires at the sixer army from a
speeding DeLorean Deadeye part a army of
Darkness is dead I'd say everywhere in
the battle scenes of ready player one in
the same theme of chun-li and tracer you
can spot a handful of them this clip of
halo Spartans charging into battle yup
it Deadites there too granted they're
probably an easy model to use for
filling out those massive battle shots
just repeats some sword wielding
skeletons a few dozen times and you have
yourself an army but in the movie
universe you have to wonder why there
would be so many Deadites remember each
of those characters is ostensibly a real
person who chose up form to play in the
Oasis the only explanation is that
people in the future really love ash
than the Evil Dead and can you blame
them groovy thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check all this cool
stuff we know you'll love tea
[Music]